I
okay then I think we can get started
with our next speaker Chris Nylund okay
thank you very much it's very nice to be
here I spent a lot of my time in my life
in Germany typically into taking some
form of exchange whether it's a language
exchange or whatever you should probably
view this talk in terms of being some
sort of exchange that's probably the
best way I can describe it perhaps if I
describe myself a little bit you'll
understand why I probably don't fit the
mold in terms of majority of people have
attended this talk I'm a lawyer
specifically I'm a tax lawyer in England
and Wales that's how I qualified I've
always worked in real estate always
worked in national or big for now a lot
of that might just sound like white
noise in some ways let's try and sort of
tie in a little bit more I do live and
work in the only city that's ever made
appt and a citizen of the year which is
Birmingham that was 2005 a red panda
called Babu just scape from its zoo and
lived at large in Birmingham for four
days I do mess around with Python and
pandas when I'm not busy being a lawyer
a husband or a father which basically
means that I do this on the train or
when everybody else is asleep which is a
little bit less than ideal but it
certainly gives me enough time to be
able to talk about something now what
I'm not going to talk about in relation
to the world of tax and data are
probably two of the hotter topics that's
because I think there might be more
adequately served elsewhere and partly
because I think it's all most important
to get this exchange program started
before we start to really start delve
deep into various bits and pieces
there's a lot of data knocking around in
tax I can only speak for the UK tax
authority Her Majesty's Revenue and
Customs but everybody knows pretty much
they have these fantastic silos full of
data in relation to various returns and
all sorts of things that have filed with
them at any given point and they're
getting very excited about data science
and what it can do to help to try and
close the tax cap equally question as
you know if only they knew what they
knew equally they're looking to actually
try and sell anonymized data in the
market now for any of the the talks at
anybody's
you know all you know this is news to
anybody I think the frightening thing
there is just how much probably people
could divine from an analyze data if it
were actually sold out in the market but
that's a data protection issue rather
than a form another data issue although
it's informed by data analysis again I'm
not going to talk about that what I'm
going to talk about is it starts with a
basic value proposition and it's simply
this I think small is beautiful I think
equally just because something's
designed for large-scale use doesn't
mean it can be can't be deployed for
small-scale use and just because
something representing use doesn't mean
it can't have a massive impact to use a
very very brief analogy if you think
about language itself not everybody is
going to write fantastic poetry when
they you know if they're a user of the
language but it doesn't change the fact
that the language is intrinsically
useful to them to start with now the
sort of tenets of the talk is really to
talk about a panda's thumb many of you
may know the joke about and if you do
about the Panda who goes into a bar to
order a drink and says I'd like beer
please and bag of crisps and the barman
says well why the big pause he says
because I'm a giant panda now pandas
have paws they don't have hands and the
consequence of that is they don't really
have a thumb but if you look at this
chap here who's about to tuck into some
bamboo it looks an awful lot like he's
actually holding it as though he had a
thumb which stephen jay gould took a
great deal of interest in and sort of
analyzed and we moved from the sort of
the icon of WWF to what the Dickens type
scenario where you have something called
exaptation this is a skeleton of a
panda's hand and if you look you can
count five fingers and yet there is a
protrusion hear of an extra bone now
that's actually just an Audrey ham bone
that the panda has co-opted over time to
serve as a thumb and muscles grow around
it and it works very serviceable if you
are in the business of eating lots and
lots of bamboo it just works very well
for holding bamboo it's something that
was never intended for the use it's
something that is quite a simple quick
and dirty unintended work
round and in many regards that's kind of
what I've tried to do with pandas a
little bit it's to scratch a particular
rich now what I'm going to say in
relation to is it to give it its general
context is that tax and tax law is going
through a bit of a sea change at the
moment certainly we fit I'll feel it
very much as a tax practitioner it has
lots of very particular needs I happen
to believe that pandas is blessed with
the attribute it they're necessary to
actually fill those needs there is a bit
of work to do now if you have to
understand tax that its most very very
basic level you've almost got a
continuum here you've got two things you
have probably innovative planning and
then compliance now one is sort of
thinking outside the box at the very
edge of the law the other is thinking in
the box keeping your head down and then
also taking all boxes as well just to
make sure that you're actually not only
doing it right but you're telling the
government that you're doing it right as
well very simply compliance is more
important than ever compliance actually
needs a lot more commoditization to be
lucrative and commoditization is hard
the reason that planning is dying is
partly because people are running away
from playing they're running away from
it from two reasons one of the courts of
the land the European Court of Justice
and the quarter popular opinion both are
pushing against people actually using
what we might construe as aggressive tax
flying those sorts of things are over a
little bit now partly that might be the
Occupy movement claiming victory partly
it's also because legislation is
beginning to trickle in and it's being
backed by wins in the courts for the tax
authorities that says we'll know we need
greater transparency we need accuracy
you're going to have to tell us lots
lots more we're going to track things
much more aggressively and the suit of
regulations called Sao or senior
accounting officer they're not only
obliged to have the right answers but
the right systems to consistently
produce the right answers as well these
are new very very novel concepts and and
you know can create a bit of an issue
for people when they're just really
predominantly working in Excel and
that's about it that's all they're doing
they're having to cope with very very
new phenomena there's also a push
vendor lock-in all the time for the
provision of these services because and
people are pushing much much more for
summarization now the problem with
compliance is that it doesn't really
attract big fees it used to be that
you'd promised to do this sort of things
that you'd be you know in with the
clients and make sure that you got the
very sexy tax planning that might go
with it it came from less complicated
times when there weren't so many boxes
to tick and then apart from that as well
you can't charge a huge fee for
something when you're just paying the
right amount of tax people tend to get a
bit more excited we'll pay you a little
bit of a reward if you find some way of
reducing tax liabilities if you're just
actually taking the boxes for them it
tends not to make them want to pay so
you have to try and cut costs cost is
the key area where you try to defend
some sort of margin in relation to
matters now the problem with that is
that tax doesn't lend itself very well
to commoditization it's very complex
it's very very black and white only if
you get down to one hundred percent zoom
otherwise it looks very gray and the
typical tax lawyer response to things is
often it depends now there are lots of
reasons for that there are multiple
variables and if that wasn't problem
enough the law can change extremely
frequently as a bare minimum it tends to
change about once a year and even if one
area of tax law changes it might have a
huge impact in another area of the code
I'll show you a little bit later why
when we sort of go through a tax engine
a lot of tax engines tend to sort of
chew up a load of data and looking at a
very very high volume and spew out an
answer they can be very effective for
very very specific questions so till
rolls and payrolls of the typical areas
you might see this let's say you have a
very very large supermarket or
convenience store and it has all of the
sales data that it's generating in a
particular year you can take a tool you
can sort of tax on you will go through
and try to spot anomalies between an
item's classification code and the tax
code that applies to it similarly on
payroll you can sort spot anomalies
where people seem to be earning a
certain amount but it's not being picked
up by the company when it's taking your
program out of income-tax out there very
weak on contextual data it's not really
a forte for them sometimes you could
argue that their solutions in search of
a problem they do one thing why
but it means that people have to walk
around constantly just a signal can i
try this can i try this it makes it a
little bit more difficult so you're
looking instead if you're trying to cut
costs and to be able to deliver on
compliance you're still looking at
something like mass customization now
what that means in its simple terms is
you've got to have empowered
practitioners in tax you basically need
people who can still do decent levels of
analysis but have the proper tools for
the job and in that regard a lot of
people are butting up against the
constraints of spreadsheets because they
just don't do the job in the way that
might need necessary for tax and the key
problem and you'll begin to see where
I'm going with this is the one thing
that spreadsheets don't do well at all
is something that's very very important
for for tax and that is to be able to
allocate figures to particular periods
on a particular basis typically you know
you also have a headline amounts of
money tax rates that apply to it that
changeover times because the company's
years don't run at the same time as the
tax authorities years you need to apply
reliefs and the relief codes can change
over time because they get cut they're
reducing their being staggered or
whatever and all of that has to be done
is that automatically as possible and
then having taken all those different
layers you then have to weave them into
a narrative quickly and effectively now
out giving the game away too much it's
fairly obvious what what that solution
might look like pandas absolutely
devours tax calculations it is
exceptionally good at doing them because
of the very simple fact that it can take
complex commands build them into a
complete time series it can then weave
those time series into a data frame that
can use in some way and they're both
sort of off the grid so you can have
lots of different inputs and different
outputs you're not constrained by the
medium of the spreadsheet alone really
and they're also quite elastic so you
can starts as flex things as time goes
on you can build lots and lots of
different facets into it now I think
pandas really can lend itself very well
to tax analysis for the simple reason
that there were there are so two things
generally in the UK you would you would
tend to have tax practitioners sometimes
who aren't necessarily legally trained
but it'll mainland Europe you'll tend to
find that tax practitioners are low
as first who then go into tax now for
Python generally when you talk about
people who've got some form of legal
training then you give them an excellent
frame of reference you give them
something that can make a lot of sense
to them there are a lot of transferable
skills between what you would do to
draft a contract which is in essence you
know form of coding for a human behavior
and what will happen in certain
circumstances if then statements
mutually exclusive collectively
exhaustive coverage of particular
scenarios in particular fact patterns in
many regards you could say that lawyers
have been doing TDD since before Charles
Babbage could even say difference engine
it's something that has existed for
quite a long time that you know will
sort of be able to do these things now
white and then has the hook in that it's
got that Shorr book or some you know
similar sorts of books that are very
very accessible and you know very good
for people who have absolutely no
experience whatsoever that's not to say
that mean they'll start from scratch
they'll bring a lot of transferable
skills in that they can then upskill
very very quickly into Python itself it
hasn't it is a medium for safe
experimentations a lot of excitement in
the UK with raspberry PI's a lot of
people are suddenly actually you know
not worried that they're going to blow
up their computer and we'll happily sort
of by Raspberry Pi and tinker and
experiment with this sort of thing
there's the openness and freedom
obviously and the flexibility but
there's option to standardize as well
now that's Python generally that's kind
of the hook it on the low side in some
ways but on the tax side then pandas has
some particularly a particularly useful
means when you're looking at this sort
of thing it does have an excellent frame
of reference so PricewaterhouseCoopers
which is one of the four largest account
see firms in the world undertook a
survey in 2013 of a hundred leading CFOs
sir chief finance officers and asked
them whether they foresaw that they be
getting rid of spreadsheets anytime soon
sixty-five percent so probably not but
eighty-five percent said that they were
absolutely keen to try and do something
a little bit more sophisticated now if
you told them they can have the benefit
of spreadsheets in some ways but
actually have additional flexibility and
power beyond that then that gets quite
exciting to them and when you think
about transferable data and what you can
do with that you've obviously got
felix is excellent Excel wings and lots
and lots of different means for people
to start tipping in from spreadsheets
there are gateways now to enable people
to actually work on this sort of thing
and obviously in the same way as Python
my own behalf Zeds book pandas has got
where's book which is just an absolutely
phenomenal guide and can walk even
someone like me through the basic making
of of pandas data frames and managing
big data I can't deny that pandas can
sort of ride on the coattails of the Big
Data hype which there's a little bit of
a time lag in the law from the mattli
very conservative profession and we tend
to only just be catching on to the fact
that this might be a good thing that's
not to say that I really buy into it is
to say that it's a hook and it's very
very useful when you're just trying to
pitch these things to people and as I
say it's theirs pandas tax superpowers
that really nothing else covers in a
satisfactory way without elavil and vba
coding or whatever so the idea might be
that you've almost sort of got
pinstriped pandas or white collar python
i'm not advocating new technology i'm
just saying actually in tax there are a
lot of new techniques that people would
use and actually it wouldn't take a lot
to train a lot of people to sort of wean
them off spreadsheets and onto data
frames and two pandas with a form of ID
you know sort of it's very open box very
democratized and enables them to do
things much more easily now that might
result in one or two things it might
result in what I would call tax BOTS
that's little things that fundamentally
solve a big tax problem that someone
just gets annoyed with or it's a little
paper cut that you have to deal with on
a daily basis alternatively what it
might be able to do is sort of provide a
bridge that it's a sort of a sketch or
prototype that you could then use to
actually go to someone who's a proper pi
finished that has opposed to someone
who's dabbling a little bit and so we
look I'm trying to do this I'd like to
take it another step further I'd like to
build something cool and it just
facilitates that dialogue in a way that
that dialogue isn't there right now it's
there on Finance in its relationship
with Python PI data it isn't with tax
and yet tax relies on very very still
has very similar requirements to finance
it's just a lot more sometimes about
percentages and about numbers and
six and its event horizon typically runs
on a year as opposed to on the
millisecond or a second now there are
some challenges one or two of them are
just things that can be ironed out very
easily pandas won't willingly leap and
roll that's to say on its rolling sums
and rolling means it tends to be able to
count on days it tends not to be able to
count on a calendar year so you can't do
rolling average or rolling mean from
today looking back one calendar year it
doesn't quite work in that way at the
moment there are workarounds and they're
bit janky certainly when things that
I've written but it is doable
nevertheless there is a need for
training because I say this is the
exchange program I'm pretty much the
only person I'm aware of that's doing
this at the moment but that's not to say
that eventually might may not be some
hook into it the evangelism I guess that
falls to me to a certain degree within
within the tactile or community
standardization is probably less
important but what is potentially
important it's probably just to have a
quick look at proof-of-concept if I if
we can sort of prove to a degree that's
something that a lot of lawyers or tax
lawyers hate can be sidestepped very
neatly using using pandas then that
hopefully as a hook in now in those
terms i'm going to talk very very
briefly about oval now any hands of
anybody from the UK okay so they're all
one or two people will attest when you
say oval to somebody in the UK most of
them think about a flightless green duck
in a nappy that van isn't i actually
named as a kid my blue bear when my
parents didn't send me for color
blindness testing apparently after after
said duck and I've sort of named the
software as a back room after that which
is the overlap rent free and that
integrated lease liability engine oval
address is a very very particular itch
in tax and that's all it looks at one
tax it's called sdlt which is stamp duty
land tax the stamp duty bit of that
derives from a tax others injured or
throw bag of taxes introduced in the
1600s by william of orange and the land
tax was then there's a bit was bolted on
when it was all rejuvenated and
modernized in 2003 by the UK chancellor
of the exchequer gordon brown so in some
ways you could argue that the story of
sdlt is that Brown is the new orange
it's
some bits of it have always remained
very much the same as it goes so for
argument's sake actually this already
guested stamp duty has been here before
or statutes atlantic's has bobbed up in
PI data specifically in London philippe
bracketed an excellent talk and in his
analysis of transaction values over time
in London underneath the 1 million pound
bracket you can spot two very distinct
lines one line is the vertical which is
Christmas generally because conveyancing
solicitors tend not to want to operate
at Christmas time it's hard to move
money around when the banks are shuts to
buy a house the horizontal line is the
threshold for stamp duty land tax so as
people come up towards where a rate
might actually change the way that rates
work on on some bits of stamp duty land
tax are that once you got a pound over
the whole lot is then taxable at a
higher rate so you can see people sort
of butting up against the very very
edges of a higher rate least duty was a
little modernized a little bit more it
didn't remain the same and that became a
bit of a difficulty really the way that
least you two used to work was that you
took a lease and you worked out how many
years worth of were in the term of the
lease when someone granted an
Occupational lease to somebody you
worked out what the average annual rent
was and you applied a very specific
delineator percentage to all that and
average annual rent for one year it was
it was very nice it was very neat it was
ok what you did was having worked that
out you went across to the stamp office
as it was called and you would present
an original document say the completed
lease and they would stamp it and you
get you know that's it this week so what
you pay for the duty do for the stamp
and then that document could then be
registered at land registry so that here
in all the times it could have been
picked up by Felipe's excellent chart
and that's very good the lawyers tended
to hold the documents because the
lawyers held the documents they they
therefore were the people that were in
charge of this and in fairness
multiplying an average annual rent by
fixed percentage was about as much as
they could do and it was ok it was all
right when sdlt on leases came in there
were have very very different
proposition and that was partly because
Lisa's have become immeasurably more
prominent in the intervening three or
four hundred years and those DLT on
lease is taxed instead every pound of
rent paid for every day of occupation
for every consistent area of demise and
its general level now somebody pointed
out that the time value of money should
be brought into account in relation to
this and so the government accept it and
it said well ok it's the net present
value of the rents then and we're going
to tax them at one of two particular
balance now in terms of the net present
value the formula they used is set out
there and you might commonly recognized
it as numpy bug number 649 where I was
one instead of 0 that's just a figure
that's used for determining net present
values on a three and a half percent
discount in the UK numpy might have been
a bit of a help subject to all the other
complication of them out to mention on
its own but it isn't anymore anyway but
the basic effect of it is that you look
at rents you look at the first five
years you find the highest rent in the
first five years that's deemed to be the
rent for the balance and then just mpv
it off that's as simple as that really
and then you just tax at the appropriate
rate the problem is that involves quite
a lot of arithmetic and quite a lot of
preparation and that is actually
probably that when the accountants
looked at this they probably had a land
grab they could have gone for this they
could have brought it in house they
could have done it but it's a relatively
low value tax I mean the tax is one
percent it's not massive they didn't see
a lot of value in it they didn't want to
do it and they just said well you
lawyers have always dealt with it carry
on but you might imagine that lawyers
that blue become lawyers and were chosen
to be lawyers because we reverse to
sunlight and garlic and that we can't be
killed by conventional weapons actually
it's a little bit more straightforward
than that generally you end up being a
lawyer largely because you're British
and you can't do numbers that seems to
be the sort of career progression path
that that pushes most of us into it
that's how we end up there so to leave
them to deal with any form of arithmetic
already it's a bit of a hassle so hmrc
wrote to the rescue interval that we're
going to procreate a web app to deal
with this and so you know it's very nice
and we'll set out you just tell us when
the lease starts when it ends and into
first five years rent and away you go
and that should be absolutely fine but
there are a couple of problems mostly it
was very late to actually come out and
so for a long time people had
make it up as they went along there's a
lot of offline preparation ironically
that goes in to just entering those
basic bits of data you've got an i/o
bottleneck generally anyway and it has
it has quite limited application sdlt
over complicates things because it tries
to catch too much when it comes into
Lisa's and very good articles have
pulled it apart far better than I can
but basically where you have do have
something where actual things are deemed
not to happen and notional things are
dealing to happen and you have credits
and disregards all the time you do have
a problem when you're just trying to dis
basic arithmetic for starters sdlt
looked at a textbook to work out when a
lease started which is great but it
doesn't reflect legal practice so you
generally had to count from a different
point so from the grounds of the leisure
had some forward 12 months that might
take in Lycia one with a particular rent
and leash year two of the particular
rent but with a bit of bit of Venus or a
bit about non overlap there so you have
to start doing time apportionment
calculations almost every time the
reason for that is because no lease
really is ever granted on this term
commencement date landlords generally
want all leases to end at a particular
time in a cycle so they'll often
backdate the official term commencement
date for release that's problem one
problem two is that then you'll often
have rent freeze injected in there
problem 3 is that VA t which is the sort
of equivalent of eval mayor vets toyota
via changes over time but you have to
pay sdlt on that as well so you've got a
lot of multiple variables there and then
a couple of extra fictions and
disregards if you had a lease that was
for this long for ten years and then you
decide you want to want it to be an
occupation for a bit long run you're
going to pay a bit more rent that sort
of happens and you agree that's that's
the new lease but a bit of overlap
between those two and the consequences
HMRC says well okay we'll let you have a
credit for the rent you've already paid
tax on so you have to reduce that as
well now already we've got a couple of
different things that all have to be
prepared by lawyers before they ever get
to the stage where they're going to
input these things into a simple web app
now generally they're doing these things
on paper with pen and paper with a
calculator and if they're very lucky and
they're not just counting days on a
calendar
that I see news time and date come but
it's not very sophisticated in terms of
how they do it and there's nothing worse
than the face of a property lawyer when
they come to you to show their
calculations and is what they've done
you said you've forgotten v80 or you've
done this or there's something not quite
right because they don't just they're
not just generally able to tweak one
thing so that gives them a general
headache and then the other problem is
that this is a very limited application
these are extracts from HMRC stamp duty
land tax manual and there are plenty of
exercise just say yes we did prepare a
web app and here are lots of incidence
where it doesn't work and it just will
not work and the result is that
generally you have to go to spreadsheets
and that's where it generally comes to
me when I have to do it so if we sort of
look at spreadsheets for a very very
straightforward least we're very little
changes but it's just a slight overhang
on the rent then there's a bit of manual
calculation then how everything has to
be prepared by hand January there are a
couple of bits of Excel foooor or
spreadsheet through that you can
undertake but but it's a bit of work and
then oops what's going on there can I
made this down here why is that
happening if you then add an extra
complication of the fact that the rent
rate changes its way through then you
have another issue if you start
introducing differential value added tax
rates as time goes on you've got to
start splitting these years again so
you've got extra data manipulation that
you've got to try number take so this
starts to make things really pretty
difficult now by comparison if you just
sort of fire up Orville which as I say
is sort of you know is a little tax
engine that does all of the hard work of
almost building the data for its
equivalents of the spreadsheet and does
it instead of back end then if we just
have something that's nice and straight
forward let's have a look at this one so
yeah that's
I wish I knew how I'm gonna say sorry
that working whoo okay so let me run
this now okay so this will actually just
very quickly generate the equivalent of
the spreadsheet that might have to do
and then collapse it all back down and
summarize it but what it's doing is
creating this on a daily basis to try
and deal with problems but the data
entry is very straightforward and you
can just sort of hack around with the
various bits and pieces so you could
change the rent so that it suddenly had
extra variables in there like you know
the walls be 80 or there was a term
shift it's all very very straightforward
to do by comparison to actually
hammering these through these things
through an X in Excel or in in
LibreOffice and you can just generate
the figures that you require very very
quickly and if something changes or
you're not certain on a fact you haven't
got a sort of stop and not do anything
you can at least do some general figures
while you get some further information
from the client and there's enough in
terms of what the lease object the that
exists or at least clashes over that
exists within within orville actually
does that you can add things in so that
if that is payable unusual quarter days
on current rents it gets caught you can
add in a rent commencement date which is
first rent calm here you can change
first rent itself which is just a dict
which then feeds itself into a data
frame that built on everything from
there that makes life a lot a good deal
more straightforward well in terms of
what it's doing what it does do is it
builds an initial data frame takes in
minimal variable inputs to start look at
the front and you haven't got to do a
lot of manual data entry it pulls in and
bolts on ready-made things that we just
know the case I know what the VA T rates
have been for the last couple of years
in the UK I don't have to reinvent it
every time unless I'm doing these things
manually but you can take applicable
that rates you can take pre defined
variables and then you just put them
together up sample them an F fill and
all of a sudden you've got a very very
nice data frame then you have to deal
with some of the legal concepts like the
fact that it's the highest rate in the
first five years my very quick and dirty
response to that is just too
slice the data frame very quickly create
a new one just bolt them back together
again with a concatenation I'm sure
there are better ways to do it but this
way works perfectly well for me at the
moment if anybody does other suggestion
I would always welcome it now there are
quite a lot of disposable columns that
you can play around with a lot more when
you're not dealing with spreadsheets now
you guys know that but people are just
sort of generally viewing things through
a spreadsheets Express I wouldn't know
that they can do that and you can also
do lots of cool things just to make it
very lawyer readable also visa law could
make sense of it by just having quite a
few group group buys now at the moment
it also outputs for posterity's sake to
csv files that then can be saved on the
digital file for a matter so at least
people know you know what the
calculation looked like what the
variable inputs were and that way you
know just have something to work on if
down the line there are additional
things that are actually required and
then beyond that as I say it just Falls
to actually sort of resem erised the
point here it's to say that that tax is
really butting up against spreadsheets
as some means to actually be able to
deliver on the new demands that are
being placed on it pandas i think is
exceptionally well-placed to be able to
deal with those needs because it it can
cope with the ambiguities of law and it
can cope with things much more readily
because it can deal with a lot of that
stuff off the grid if you like in terms
of what turns up in the data frame it
can just filter things through before
they get into the data frame to start
with it's very very handy there's a lot
of work to do as I say in relation to it
but at least as a proof of concept I've
made something that would ordinarily
take say an hour and a half to two hours
of a lawyer's time at appropriate rates
down to something that can be done in a
few minutes with the right tool and
that's quite a compelling proposition it
doesn't it's not the sexiest thing
you'll ever see it's certainly not the
most complicated thing that had been
here but what it is is valuable
nevertheless because even though not
much seems to happen in relation to it
if you present it in the right market it
means a great deal and two lawyers
generally these are the tax
practitioners these are the sorts of
things that they need to know about
because it can make their life
immeasurably more straightforward
they weren't becoming here with you know
as I say great great deals of input or
whatever I don't think really to the
scientific Python stack but the flip
side to that is that they are quite able
to draw something meaningful from it
that's valuable even if it looks like
it's very very straight forward to you
and that's a fantastic position for you
to be in that you have a skill that is
exceptionally highly valued elsewhere
that's it more thank you does anybody
have any questions so I wonder how the
text offers checks these calculations
and your texts it's a very good question
tax in the UK is done on a
self-assessment basis so they just trust
that you're going to do it yourself
properly and then they just rely on the
system of audit to check it the more
readily you can point to a proper audit
system the better and that's what the
senior accounting rules I senior
accounting officer also designed to deal
with but if you haven't got anything or
at best you've got to print out from the
web app that says well I did this and
they'll say well how did you come to
these numbers often the record you know
the lawyers scribbles on the back of an
envelope might not be on the file and
and everyone just sort of shrug their
shoulders and they're not quite sure
this gives a much more sort of
transparent accounting trail if you like
but the short answer is it's very hard
to reverse engineer some of these things
a lot of the time because you've got
people who can't do math doing it and
second question is there an official set
of test cases where they have a very
validated output for certain situations
do they say does the text office say
this is the right amount of text you
should pay no no there aren't there's
nothing of that sort at the moment and
as I say generally they will rely on
people themselves getting it right they
tend compliance type stuff making sure
that you get the figures right tends to
be an issue that sorted out before never
gets to the courts for argument's sake
is just a tax officer coming and saying
i'd like to see how you've calculated
this its principles of law so as it not
did you put this number incorrectly but
should you put this number in at all
that tends to be the sort of stuff that
ends up in the courts I don't blame you
if you have no more questions by the way
that's quite enough tax law for no no
brilliant yeah so have you have you
presented this to other lawyers what did
they think or what are your current
plans for advocating it this is very
much a side project at the moment as
opposed to so when I speak to friends
who are in the profession whether or not
they're at my firm they're excited by
this sort of thing of the idea generally
I think it at the moment it's just a
massive help for me because it makes my
job a lot more straightforward but in
the longer term I think even as I said
there are sort of two levels there are
tax practitioners themselves I think
they're the next step or their they bear
the Gateway for this sort of thing what
they're delivering is a service to
property lawyers now for those property
lawyers they probably would need
something that's got a flask front end
and you can do for you a few bits more
than more straightforward you think even
they might balk even it I sort of my
Python notebook but I do think that
that's possible as a second step cool
that's good thank you thank you very
much
you
you